you know it's been a tough few weeks I
guess it's been a tough few months
everyone's kind of down on account of
the pandemic and the riots and the arson
and and the chaos and the mayhem so I
figure this would be a good opportunity
to take a look back on some of the great
moments from the most entertaining
President of the United States that
we've ever had good question yeah go
ahead sure she's shocked that I picked
her no it's like in a state of shock I'm
not thinking that's okay I know you're
not thinking you never do I'm sorry no
go ahead
you've called women you don't like fat
pigs dogs slobs and disgusting animals
your Twitter account only Rosie
O'Donnell this moment this is actually
my favorite Trump moment period ever I
think this is the moment when he went
from the sort of funny side candidate
that everyone was getting a kick out of
- this guy is gonna be the President of
the United States is when he took this
you know total brutal question on him
right at the top of the debate you've
said all these horrible things about
women he did say terrible things about
women and he takes it and he flips it
she has only Rosie O'Donnell three words
probably about three most important
words he said in his entire campaign
including build the wall it's just
awfully good that someone with the
temperament a little Trump is not in
charge of the law in our country because
you'd be in jail last night I called
Hillary a nasty woman but this stuff is
all relative after listening to Hillary
rattle on and on and on
I don't think so badly of Rosie
O'Donnell anymore please pause here for
a moment
I remember this whole nasty woman thing
cuz he obviously she has a nasty woman
and he said she's a nasty woman and the
left really loved this because they
thought they thought we were playing by
the old rules so they thought you that's
just something you can't say this is a
big faux pas Donald Trump
fool that idiot he doesn't know the
rules of politics we said it and they
ran with it and then all of them started
calling themselves nasty woman said I'm
a nasty woman all these kind of crazy
blue hair you know really angry ultra
feminists I'm a nasty woman I'm
disgusting
I'm absolutely repulsive and the effect
of that was not the effect they wanted
because I think the reaction from most
normal people was like well you know we
weren't gonna say it that's not that's
impolite so I wasn't gonna say it but
Donald Trump is saying the things that
previously we were not allowed to say in
politics you think that that's gonna
kill him actually probably it's going to
send him right to the White House
what a stupid question that is what a
stupid question but I watched you a lot
you ask a lot of stupid questions on
Roberts go ahead John no no John Roberts
go ahead CNN's fake news questions from
CNN is fake news I don't take questions
from st. John Roberts of Fox this is so
wild to look back at this in retrospect
because don't forget fake news was an
attack that the left launched at the
right specifically at this website at
the Daily wire there was this Google Doc
that went viral and they said these are
fake news accounts and they're part of
the reason Trump won so don't look at
fake news and then the right was able to
take fake news and say way to say we're
not fake news we're actually just
reporting what's going on you guys
actually are fake news because you run
fake stories and you pretend to be
objective and you're not
we're actually honest about our point of
view so then you see this this clip of
Trump he's saying why would I take a
question from you at CNN you are liars
you're propagandists for the left what
and you think yeah why didn't a lot of
presidents do this in the past why did
we play along with these guys and and
pretend with this fiction that they were
objective reporters even though they're
just carrying water for the left and
then let them run roughshod over us we
could have just said I know you're a
liar and a dummy and a propagandist I'm
not gonna listen to you what it's so
simple now but I think we were so
wrapped up in this kind of I don't know
liberal ideology this liberal regime we
didn't realize how simple it is to just
call it like it is it's great to be here
with a thousand wonderful people or as I
call it a small intimate dinner with
some friends or as Hillary calls it her
largest crowd of the season
is visceral response to attack people on
their appearance short tall fat ugly my
goodness that happened in junior high
are we not way above that would we not
all be worried to have someone like that
in charge of the nuclear alert mr. camp
I never attacked him on his look and
believe me this plenty of subject matter
right there
this is what I remember I remember it
from the debate because it opened up
there is actually even more context to
it which is like Oh everyone's making
their opening statement and Trump's
opening today was just Rand Paul has no
business being on this stage he's
pulling it nothing why is he even here
and then to use that he would say look I
never attacked you on your looks but I
could you think I actually like Rand
Paul but that's Trump Trump doesn't care
he's like the honey badger I tell you
watch CNN should be ashamed of itself
having you working for them you are a
rude terrible person you shouldn't be
working for CNN go ahead in in Jim's
defense I've traveled with him in
Washington he's a diligent reporter who
big fan of yours either so I understand
to be honest I'm prepared to do this job
what say you I think he's the worst
president maybe in the history of our
country I think he's been a disaster
he's been weak he's been in effect sir
mr. president a question no personal
like can you give us a count be
reminding us can you give us a question
I'm not going to give you can you say
caddie you are fake dude sir
you know I wasn't there this is
something Trump does that a lot of
politicians didn't do before him but
it's a very helpful tactic I've noticed
it even in debates that I've done myself
which is when someone tries to interrupt
you just don't let them you don't you
actually don't have to as sometimes
speakers or debaters or politicians they
just for they will to they let them do
it
but you actually don't have to you can
just you know obviously in certain
moments that might be to your advantage
to let them get out there stupid points
you can smack it down
but otherwise if it's just being
pestered by Jim Acosta just keep talking
and they will wilt or you'll just keep
talking at the same time and they won't
look ridiculous and Trump just knows it
because he's you know he's only that
Obama question Obama criticized you what
do you think oh I think he's the
absolute worst person that's ever walked
the face of the earth he goes on for
three minutes about it I know Hillary
met my campaign manager and I got the
chance to meet the people who are
working so hard to get her elected there
they are the heads of NBC CNN CBS ABC
there's the New York Times right over
there and the Washington Post they're
working overtime this is not laughing so
much about that one anymore that's it
all right wow that was great I like that
it ends there I forgot about that whole
Al Smith dinner the the dinner with him
you know in the white tie and Tails and
everything that dinner is a relic from
an older age which is that these
politicians would come together it's
usually not on camera the most of the
dinners they do are not broadcast and
they're they tell these jokes about one
another and if they roast one another
and it's very collegial and that could
exist when the center held in the
country when we all basically agreed
about the same sorts of things after the
last few decades where the left has
aggressed
so much where the left is no longer just
protesting this little policy or that
policy but they're protesting the
American flag itself right like the
Colin Kapernick protest where they're
they're really tearing down the country
they're deriving patriotism in a way
that we really haven't seen before in
that moment where there's not a liberal
consensus really anymore you can't do
that dinner in the way you did in the
past Oh ha ha you made a joke about me
Oh ha ha I made a joke about you and
don't worry you know the liberal
candidates gonna win in the end you
can't really do it because Trump is
actually threatening something about
their regime is threatening something
about the news organizations he's
threatening something about obviously
the election in 20 2016 and in 2020 and
so you see Hillary she's she kind of
playing the fake laugh at the beginning
and then by the end of it she's not yeah
she's not laughing so much anymore
not so collegial anymore because
actually some real winds or on the table
can we maximize them in the time we've
got left sure hope so and at the very
least we'll get some more less
[Music]
you
[Music]